so as the economy evolved out of an
information economy into a purpose
economy which is really the future of
work and it's a future of our economy
and society it's an incredible
opportunity I'm so jealous of people
graduating from college right now it's
an opportunity to be at an economy and
to be an innovator in this new economy
where you're able to both do good and do
well and to really do that in a really
authentic way so my advice to folks
graduating now I mean first and foremost
is to spend your 20s getting to know
yourself I think too often we look to
outside influences we look at what
people expect of us and instead of just
trying to really figure out who we are
what drives purpose for us what matters
to us and to spend our 20s just rubbing
up against the world and getting to know
ourselves so that we can figure out once
we have that strong core that's strong
sense of purpose how we can then go out
and create value in the world and I
think unfortunately universities do a
pretty poor job of doing that
so in some sense your 20s is about
getting your real college degree by
going out there and learning in the real
world and learning about yourself my
experience the most important thing is
to get to know yourself and you get to
know yourself most often by putting
yourself in different circumstances and
trying different things I think in
education we tend to go through the same
experience over and over again for four
years instead of having a diversity of
experiences taking English and then math
is not really that different and
experience when I was in college the
things that were different we're
studying abroad I did a lot of work at a
local prison as a teacher these are the
things that actually teach you who you
are and those are the things we really
need to invest in in our 20s
you